authorities have banned large-scale
demonstrations here in berlin against
measures to stop
the spread of the coronavirus the
organizers had called a new protest this
coming saturday
and thousands were expected to attend at
a demonstration at the start of this
month in berlin police
said many people taking part had ignored
rules on social distancing and
the wearing of face masks putting public
health at risk the
protesters include anti-vaccination
activists and conspiracy theorists but
also
some of germany's most notorious
right-wing groups
our political correspondent nina haser
now joins us from our parliamentary
studios here in berlin that the
organizers don't want to accept the ban
tell us more several groups are already
mobilizing their supporters online to
still come to berlin this weekend
they use chat services like telegram so
it's quite easy to follow their
conversations and they're saying that
it's important to send the message and
to not
accept this ban and still go to berlin
of course this
is something where authorities are alert
and
the organizers had announced that
several thousand
people would come again and so it is
going to be an exciting couple of days
so you say authorities are alert how
will they
go ahead and try to stop this
well the berlin senator for the interior
has already announced that this time
around the police
will act decisively and rigorously and
not
tolerate any violations of existing
hygiene rules
and that they will break up those mass
gatherings if they happen despite the
ban the senator
justified the ban by saying this is not
an attack on the freedom of assembly
this is a decision in favor of
protecting public health and he said
that the demonstrators behavior at the
earlier demo
earlier this month had shown that they
clearly didn't want
to adhere to those hygiene rules and so
a large-scale event with so many
participants at a time when we're still
in the middle of a pandemic
is simply too risky that's what he said
but he also added
that and that is an important point when
you talk about who's actually planning
to come to berlin this weekend
he said that lots of those groups have
clearly defined their goal
as saying this is no longer just about
the anti-corona measures this
is about overthrowing the german
government because they're not
legitimate that's what these people are
saying
and so the senator for the interior has
said this is an attack
against the free democratic system well
some of these protests have attracted
large crowds in the past in germany is
the public still behind the government's
covet strategy here
there are several agencies who conduct
regular polls who want to find out what
germans think about the anti-corona
measures
and a very recent poll suggests that the
german government still has
massive support from the vast majority
of germans
that poll earlier this week suggested
that 87 percent of germans
are in favor of banning large scale
events at the moment
and there were similar figures for uh
similar measures like the wearing of
face masks in the public sphere
dw political correspondent nina garza
thank you nina
while we're on the topic let's take a
look at some of the latest developments
in the coronavirus pandemic
india has reported more than 67 000 new
cases in the past 24 hours
raising the country's number of
confirmed infections to 3.2 million
kazakhstan has signed a deal to get
supplies of russia's first potential
covet-19
vaccine once clinical trials are
complete
about 3700 people in sweden were told
that
at all in era that they had the
coronavirus due to a fault in a testing
kit
from china and germany's travel warning
for more than 160 countries outside the
eu
will be extended by two weeks due to
continued concerns
about the coronavirus pandemic
you